to joe cheers
raising a glass to reopening at the
bristol old vic actors back in
rehearsals in real life
for the first time in months the cast in
a coved bubble
to allow them back on the boards there
is that sort of dread that will i ever
get back to it will i ever be performing
again and you know
there was the threat of theaters closing
and all that kind of stuff and so to be
back in a theater and to be doing a play
and
to have a live audience to have a you
know first day of rehearsals it's just
it's just amazing
audiences will return for this
production of touching the void next
week but only
at one-third capacity this is the oldest
working theater in the english-speaking
world
and survived cholera outbreaks if it's
to make it through covid
they need those restrictions to be
temporary but the numbers only really
stack up in theater
when we can get back to the kind of real
atmosphere of a full house
21st of june is a vital date if we can
get there by the 21st of june
suddenly the whole theatrical economy
catches fire really really trying to get
the best of bristol
the ushers box office and bar staff are
all back
too part of a massive return to work
for a sector shut down for months
this is a huge moment for around a
hundred thousand hospitality businesses
that haven't had the luxury
of opening outside and can finally
unlock their doors after months
of forced closure but being able to open
isn't the same as being viable which is
why the next step on the road map
is the crucial one bristol's arnolfini
arts center reopens this week
too in ordinary times they welcome 500
000 people a year part of a british
creative industry
worth more than 110 billion pounds to
the economy
super exciting we installed it in
november and it's only been up for five
days so it's really good to get people
back in
finally have a look and the bar
can open inside too relief to the brewer
who runs it after a
terrible year you can see the guys in
the brewery walking around with smiles
on their faces
it's it's a beautiful thing so we've
been
pretty active for the last month so now
um
and it's uh it's great to see all these
people just opening up and
you know the order's coming in again for
thousands of businesses and millions of
workers this
is a moment of optimism but continued
restrictions
and our reservations may mean the good
cheer lasts only as long
as the roadmap stays on course paul
kelso sky news in bristol